the Olympics announced flag football as
a new sport in 2028 I'm going to build
the best possible offense and best
possible defense for the USA our
quarterback it's got to be Patrick
Mahomes running back bejn Robinson he
can catch he fast receiver tyi Hill me
as the next receiver just pick me tight
end definitely got to be Travis Kelce
how old is Travis Kelce right now he's
34 yeah we going to go with a different
TI uh oh Cal pick we could pick Cal pcks
yeah all right we can put Parsons right
there for rusher DB jayen Ramsey Patrick
Satan put me at safety cuz I can play
both ways M back that team going to be
unstoppable bro we got straight ball
Hawks on our
team